most people just intuitively believe you
should attack your opponent where they
are weak and you should not not attack
your opponent in an area where you
yourself are weak Rove said no it's the
opposite attack your opponent's
strengths you don't need to attack their
weaknesses their weaknesses are manifest
attack your opponent's strengths turn
your opponent's strengths into a problem
for them this was most clearly done in
2004 when Bush was running against John
Kerry the Iraq War was a big issue in
the 2004 race John Kerry was a military
veteran a decorated one even though John
Kerry's Behavior after the war was
shameful and George Bush did not really
have all that much military service so
the the common sense said don't attack
John Kerry on the military but that's
what the Republicans did specifically
the Swift boat Veterans for truth
attacked Kerry said his service was a
bunch of BS he was a grandstander a
Showboat or a ribbon collector and it
worked the strategy did work